WWE legend The Ultimate Warrior, whose real name was James Hellwig,...
...died Tuesday night at 5:50 PM when he collapsed outside of an Arizona hotel...
...while walking to his car with his wife.
He was 54.
While cause of death is still undetermined,...
...the shocking news comes after the Warrior made a long overdue return to the WWE...
...this past weekend, being inducted into their hall of fame...
...and appearing at both Wrestlemania 30 on Sunday and RAW on Monday.
The WWE released the following statement saying:...
..."Warrior began his WWE career in 1987...
...and quickly went on to become one of the biggest stars in WWE history.
Warrior became WWE Champion at WrestleMania VI,...
...defeating Hulk Hogan in an epic encounter.
We are grateful that just days ago,...
...Warrior had the opportunity to take his rightful place in the WWE Hall of Fame...
...and was also able to appear at WrestleMania 30 and Monday Night Raw...
...to address his legions of fans.